the more I look into the details of
Donald Trump's recently supposedly
excellent medical exam the more I'm
convinced that at least some elements of
the report just are not telling the
truth and there's a lot of different
questions about that study one of them
is the idea that anybody could be in
quote excellent health given a regime of
no exercise bad diet and advancing
cholesterol that is already kind of
weird to me but I want to go through
some of these elements piece by piece
starting with the reports claim that
Donald Trump is 6-3 and 239 pounds I
told you yesterday that that seemed
unlikely to me and I think more research
into this and for example Barack Obama
is known to be just over 6 feet tall 6 1
supposedly is the height of Barack Obama
I'm gonna put up on the screen for our
television and video audience a picture
of Donald Trump and President Obama
standing next to each other on
Inauguration Day and as you see from the
red line that we've added to this image
at most President Trump is as tall as
President Obama and arguably he's about
an inch shorter than President Obama at
the absolute maximum we're talking about
someone who is six one two maybe six one
and a half additionally we have pictures
of Donald Trump next to former baseball
player Alex Rodriguez Alex Rodriguez is
known to be 6-3 sometimes athletes
height is exaggerated but he seems
several inches taller than Donald Trump
and we have a picture of Donald Trump
next to Jeb Bush and again Jeb Bush also
known to be 6-3 and he looks I mean
several year for three or four inches
taller than Donald Trump and Trump not
noticeably slouching here so to begin
with Trump is definitely not 6-3 Trump
himself claimed to be 6-2 the last time
he renewed his driver's license and to
be perfectly honest people often
exaggerate on their driver's licenses my
driver's license says that I'm five nine
and I can assure you I am NOT five nine
because at least in Massachusetts they
just ask you how tall are you they don't
actually take your height so why would
it matter
if Donald Trump is 6 1 or 6 2 or 6 3 the
reason it matters is that at 6 3 and 239
pounds
Trump's reported weight in this test
Trump would be just shy of obese if you
make him just slightly heavier or just
slightly shorter he becomes obese so at
6:30 239
Trump's BMI is twenty nine point nine
now to be clear BMI is not a perfect
measure we've talked before if you're a
bodybuilder and you have huge muscle
mass you would show up as obese unbe mi
but listen Trump is no bodybuilder right
we know that it's a pretty good estimate
so at six three to thirty nine Trump's
BMI is twenty nine point nine which puts
him as overweight if Trump remains at
239 239 pounds but his height is only
six to much more realistic Trump is
obese and we know Trump doesn't want to
be reported as being obese in the media
and if you maintain that Donald Trump is
6-3 which we don't believe but you
increase his weight just two pounds to
241 Trump also scores as obese according
to BMI realistically Donald Trump is not
6-3 and he's definitely heavier than 239
some estimates put him at roughly
anywhere from 255 even up to 270 so
Trump is obese and that is something
that should be reported right shouldn't
the the American public have a right to
know that the president by accepted
measures is an obese person but of
course that wouldn't work for Trump
because he's the best and he's the
smartest and he's in tremendous health
and everything is just absolutely
fantastic now as far as Trump being in
quote excellent health we've learned
from the studies that were done that
Trump has core coronary atherosclerosis
and a moderate risk of having a heart
attack his coronary calcium score went
from 34 in 2009 to 98 and 2013 to 133 at
this most recent test and he is on more
and more medication to control that it
is not crazy for someone his age who is
both obese and doesn't exercise and eats
a ton of fast food his cholesterol
I was also high but once you see data
that doesn't make any sense isn't it
reasonable to question everything that
we're supposedly being told by this test
and also very strangely the test says
that Trump doesn't wear dentures that
seems like a minor thing right why don't
why do we care that Trump doesn't wear
dentures because of trumps strange word
slur not long ago speculation ran
rampant is that part of trumps possible
dementia was Trump on some kind of
medication what was going on and one
relatively benign explanation was Oh
Trump wears dentures and they slipped
let me remind you of the incident where
Trump devolved into sort of
unintelligible slurring during a speech
not violence and it is time for young
and moderate voices all across the
Middle East to claim for themselves a
bright and beautiful future so today let
us rededicate ourselves to a path of
mutual understanding and respect
let us rethink old assumptions and open
our hearts and minds right to possible
and possibilities and finally I ask the
leaders of the region politically
religious right Israeli and Palestinian
Jewish and Christian and Muslim to join
us in the noble quest for lasting peace
thank you god bless you god bless Israel
God bless the Palestinians and God bless
the United States thank you very much
so the most benign explanation was he
has dentures but we're told he has no
dentures and that was probably dry mouth
caused by sudafed and I know many people
with dry mouth and that's not how they
talk so again raising even more
questions
adventurous was probably the most
reasonable and the most generous
explanation I agree what happened there
the other explanations we came up with
yeah we're much worse much much worse
yeah and we are told and I said at the
time rich people usually have dental
implants they don't have dentures and
indeed we're told Trump has no dentures
and then lastly we've got the cognitive
assessment the Montreal cognitive
assessment that Trump was given we
actually found what it looks like and
we're gonna put it up on the screen for
people to check out I mean it's
literally there's drawings of a lion a
rhinoceros
and a giraffe just kidding I know that
it's a camel it's I know that it's a
camel and one of the things you have to
do is just like 10% is just identifying
those animals the idea that this was
going to reliably diagnose whether Trump
might be starting to suffer from from
early symptoms of dementia is completely
laughable and as I mentioned at the
bottom you'll notice that you get six
points just for telling the interviewer
what the day month and year and location
of the interview is that that is taking
place so this is more useful for
neurological disorders this is more
useful for more advanced stages of
dementia and dementia like conditions
but I don't know how much we're really
going to learn from this overall and and
to put a fine point on that Ronald
Reagan would likely have passed this
test during his presidency even though
we now know in retrospect that he
already had some of the early symptoms
of Alzheimer's while he was President of
the United States that's my sort of
final assessment on the medical exam I
don't know if we'll ever hear about it
again because the trumpets by and large
have been completely placated by the
video you just watched was made possible
by support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad